it just smells like fresh life bruh it
smells like
oh my gosh whoa i can't even explain the
smell it's just
like that like damn what's up gq it's
low skies and these are my
10 essentials let's get it
[Music]
yes so one of my things is
water i drink a lot of water like every
single day probably like 20 bottles of
water and i feel it like hydrating me as
i drink it so i think that's why i like
it i'm not a big like
juice person but i like aquafina i think
that's my number one
it's just the best it tastes the best
this is pretty much my go-to
all times clear clean you dig
this one is a chain that i got made by
icebox it's very important to me because
it has my mom in it
with me on there as a baby and then it
has her name
shelby on the back we both got one i got
my mom one and my cell phone for my
album shall we this piece is very
important to me i keep it with me
everywhere you feel me just to remember
how far i came who i do it for i love my
mom she's very important to me she plays
a big key in my life so shout out to her
shout out to shelby
put her in some diamonds
i got some racks we all need money to
survive so i like to keep a low pack on
me
i might not even spend it all on myself
i might need to go get my son some milk
or some diapers or something
you know you never know what you might
need it for i just like to keep it on me
just in case i probably won't even spend
it i probably just put it back in the
bank
these are the two things i need to get
my mind right when you need to relieve
some stress
this is important to have around me in
the studio because this is what we do in
the studio we're smoking like chimneys
to be honest
we blowing down so we need a whole lot
of these and we need a whole bunch of
these
and i like about these papers is it
comes a lot in the pack but
i really be smoking because i'll be
running through these whole things whole
packs of these
fire yeah white tee
this one ain't a new one but i know me
trying to keep me some new ones some
fresh ones it doesn't matter i wear
hanes hanes is the ones i get i'll get
some polo ones or some nautical ones
when i can catch them but i always keep
a white tee with me because
i'm a sweaty person like i'll go
somewhere and i might sweat out this
t-shirt so i need another shirt to put
on so
this is very convenient for me and it
goes with everything you never go wrong
with white teeth
i wear some smalls but if i buy them
small after i wear them once if i buy
them
as a small i just throw them away
because when you wash the small t-shirts
they already get super tight and
i know that's why i normally get a
medium so when you wash them they pretty
much turn into the smalls
the white tea people the people that
wear white tees every day or all the
time they know exactly what i'm talking
about
so yeah shout out to the family haynes
hit me up
all right so this is wild bill's beef
jerky
this to me is like the realest beef
brookie ever made like because it's
chewy
they got the good saltiness on it like
it's been my favorite ever since i was a
kid ever since i was growing up around
here i've been eating this
probably since i was like 10 years old
and it's been faithfully like
every day because i i don't really eat
that much so
this is something i could always like
get in my stomach i can always eat it
pretty much at any time you feel me so
i love these it's very convenient for me
because i'll be on the go sometimes and
stuff too so i think it's a pa thing
though because
i don't be seeing these anywhere else in
the world i only be seeing them
like in my hometown or where i'm from
but yeah shout out to wild bills man
the best beef jerky in the world they've
redid the bag or something because it
didn't always look like this i would
have had the older bag video but
i always get the original i won't do all
that teriyaki and all that stuff it
doesn't mean much added to it it's just
right bro like it's perfect
anybody that i let try this jerky to
they love it
they love it they say it's the best they
ever tried for real so i know i'm not
crazy
my hair ties i like to keep these
because these are like lighters kind of
you just lose a lot of hair ties when
you have long hair and stuff now
i see why females too like be keeping
these shits in their purse whatever
my hair nowadays is pretty much like
starting to just get in the ways be too
poofy so i gotta pull it up so
what i like about these ones is they're
thick and they're not the easy break
ones
these don't break easily so i like these
probably go through like three or four
of these a day with my hair because i do
be breaking them and stuff i don't know
what just happened so you got to keep
them
on deck my keys
yeah these are pretty i mean you need
these to drive and do stuff or whatever
so
when i'm not working or on the road or
whatever i'll be back home
and i like to drive my cars i like to
drive myself places i know some famous
people or rappers they get drivers and
stuff but
i really prefer driving myself i'm just
alone so i like having my keys though
with me
drive the car get into my house into my
room
whatever i need to do these are
convenient like i love driving my car
both my car i got a couple my nicest car
is probably the
2019 dodge challenger just some cool
[ __ ] that new thing coming soon i ain't
saying what i'm getting yet but
i'm gonna get something fire fire this
is
some cologne javanchi shout out to them
i'm a big
smell person cologne person like people
is a product but i like a lot of the
female
like fragrances they be smelling real
good
female ferguson's got some good stuff
too i go shopping at bath and body works
and stuff and get
all of my stuff like i even get some
stuff from there like some colognes and
stuff stuff they'd be having candles i'm
just big into the smells the fragrances
need to smell good nobody wants a sneaky
person you don't want a stinky dude so
i try to stay as clean as possible this
and lotion i keep it on day gotta have
it
yeah cologne game
last but not least we got my bag
shout out to jay cure shout out to him
over there at west coast secure
he actually had this bag it was the high
time show
and he was there or whatever he had this
bag on him i've been telling him that
that i wanted one of these
because he'd be having all that
exclusive german anybody know jay kerry
we have an all that exclusive trip but
he had this one
and i showed you that emergency stash i
had a little bit of money on me
so i was like bro i need that bag so i
literally bought the bag right off him
like i think i spent
8k i think 78k maybe i don't know the
full price but
he gave me this like emptied all his
[ __ ] out of it and gave it to me that's
love shout out to bro
i [ __ ] it up i used it so much it's
like broke
see that's just hanging from there it's
broke i love this bag so much
i use it for everything traveling
anywhere i go i pretty much take it with
me like
anything even if i'm not on the road or
whatever going to the studio i think
it seems like i bring a lot of stuff
with me even when i try not to so
this just comes in clutch put anything
in here
all your essentials whatever you need
ready to go shout out to
lv louis vuitton this is fire and [ __ ]
one of my favorite bags
thank you guys for checking out my 10
essentials in gq
gang